I'm wondering what the first thing you
do is after wrapping a John wick with me
do you go on a nice long vacation is it
rest or is it oh after wrapping the film
yeah yeah you know I wasn't filming
where I live so it's just you know
getting home and catching up with
friends and family and some couch time
is there a way for you to come down from
all that that John wick madness all that
getting thrown through glad I'm sure
it's months of getting thrown to glass
being soaked dude pouring rain riding
horses down New York is there a way for
you to come down from all that
you mean like while I'm filming day to
day and then afterwards you know when
you have to leave all that behind um
yeah I mean you get a little you know
when you finished something so intense
it's like you're so tired but then
you're also kind of Restless
you know when I when I first got back
home I basically didn't see anybody for
like five days mmm I just shut it all
down and basically I seen a little bit
yeah I have to leave John with uh yeah I
don't know if I left it behind but there
was a little bit of recovery and just
give it some cheap back yeah and then
day-to-day you just basically try to
recover from the day and then prepare
for the next day mm-hmm which is fun I
mean this is like great I'm not doing
John wick so it's like whatever costs
whatever it takes what's ever happening
it's like there's no complaining mm-hmm
when you first you know when you first
got into acting and then when you
transitioned into action was there ever
a time when you envisioned something
like you killing someone with a book
something that just amazing like that no
yeah I mean John wick was the first time
I ever heard about killing someone with
a pencil yeah you know yeah I mean that
really introduced me to the idea of
weapons of opportunity mm-hmm you know
what that could be
so definitely my eyes have changed sense
of like what if I really if I put my
John wick on anything in this ring oh my
god it's just a it's just a weapon I'm
wondering I'm actually wondering about
that scene in the in the
because I think I saw some that the
person you're finding that isn't an NBA
player yeah if you have a basketball
player how does how did you find that
dynamic with him because I'm sure he
didn't have much acting experience of
land
um I hate Bo bond had done some
commercials and done some on-camera
stuff but it's an athlete and he really
he committed to the training so he came
into the dojo he worked with the stunt
guys they had the choreography pretty
early it changed a little bit but they
definitely had to get to know him so his
strengths and what you know in the time
frame what they could do and him being
an athlete it was great and then we got
to train a little bit together and then
we did some fake fighting did some
dancing yeah I mean he was great yeah a
great character too uh it's not often I
ask just how just how you did something
but I'm very great about the scene that
the motorcycle chase on the bridge was
that completely new on the motorcycle
was that that yeah so it's it's part of
like we were hoping to do new cut not
new kind spoke kind of not new kinds of
action but action in different
situations so we had done gun foo which
is like doing some judo or Jiu Jitsu
with a weapon and combining those
tactics and skills we didn't carve food
you know kind of shooting out of the car
you know slamming into people with the
car and then chads2 helps me the
director had this idea of kind of
putting it on motorcycles and on horses
yeah so the motorcycles is actually one
of the first environments where we had
to do something that wasn't in the real
world so we had to do I mean it's a long
process of how they did it but it's like
wind machine motorcycle ends people
moving motorcycles on trolleys and kind
of dancing that still really long shots
mm-hmm you know so there were sequences
and so there's basically we're doing it
but not on motorcycles and it's in CG
amazing I'm very excited to see what
kind of foods you guys can come up major
that's crazy food yeah